J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: We're
talking about nucleophilic
substitution reactions.
And today we're going to talk,
in the next lecture as well,
about mechanistic tools.
How you find out what the
mechanism is.
You can talk about plausible
mechanism, but whether that's
really it or not, and almost
always there are several,
requires experimentation.
So we're going to look at
experimental tools you can use
to decide what the mechanism of
the reaction is.
So last time we saw a whole
bunch of examples of
nucleophilic substitution
reactions, where a nucleophile
approaches a compound that has a
low LUMO, the substrate.
It reacts in a particular
solvent to give the product in
which the nucleophile has
replaced the leaving group.
So now we're interested in what
the mechanism of that is.
We talked last semester about
the possibility of attacking
on the carbon of the sigma-star,
and the leaving
group leaving with the electrons
that were formerly
in the R-L bond.
That's certainly plausible, the
question is
whether it's true.
Because as you'll see, there are
other
possibilities as well.
So there are many different
mechanisms. In fact they're
not all the same.
But many of them fall in the
same two
classes as you'll see.
And the one we're going to talk
about first is called
nucleophilic substitution, SN.
Substitution, nucleophilic 2
means second order in
kinetics, and you'll see what
that means.
So SN2, nucleophilic
substitution.
And we're interested, as I said
in the pragmatic logic of
proving a mechanism with
experiment and theory.
Now this kind of logic isn't
like the logic they teach you
in philosophy or mathematics.
Things are rarely 100% proven.
But there's a practical use to
know how these things work,
because they can help you in
designing new reactions, or
changing the conditions to make
a reaction work better.
So you'll see what it means to
prove a
mechanism in organic chemistry.
And actually, mostly it involves
disproving all the
alternative mechanisms. You
remember Sherlock Holmes in
The Adventure of the Beryl
Coronet, said "It's an old
maxim of mine, that when you
have excluded the impossible,
whatever remains, however
improbable, must be the
truth." That's generally the
logic of how you prove things
in chemistry.
But the problem is you have to
disprove "all the alternative
mechanisms, which means you have
to imagine all the
alternative mechanisms in
disprovement.
Of course it's always a
possibility that there's one
you haven't thought of that's
the real McCoy.
Now let's just look at what has
to happen.
You have to break the R-L bond,
leaving group has to
leave, and you have to make the
new bond.
So there has to be a
dissociation and there has to
be an association.
And you could classify the
possible mechanisms in the
sequence that's involved in
these two processes.
You could first have
dissociation, and then
association.
And we'll see that actually
happens--
that's called the SN1 reaction.
You can have association
followed by dissociation,
which happens, but not with
carbon.
And you'll see also the
possibility of a simultaneous
or a concerted reaction as you
call it, where you make the
new bond at the same time you
break the old one, so that
they come at the same time.
That seems to pretty much cover
the territory of
how you can do it.
So you can have concerted, where
they both happen at the
same time,
association/dissociation, or
dissociation followed by
association.
And we can imagine
reaction-coordinate diagrams
for these, and geometries.
So in the concerted, the
nucleophile is coming in and
attacking the carbon at the same
time the leaving group is
leaving, and that's a transition
state.
You can have a pentavalent
carbon intermediate.
So you first make the new bond,
and only subsequently do
you break the old bond.
Or you could break the old bond,
and get a trivalent
intermediate, and then
subsequently
make the new bond.
So if we look at the reaction
coordinate diagram, the first
one just has a transition state,
but the other two have
intermediates.
Either a pentavalent
intermediate of pentavalent
carbon, or a trivalent carbon
intermediate.
As I've drawn it there, the
first step is rate limiting.
We talked about the complex
reaction of two steps, where
either the first or the second
step would be rate limiting.
It would be possible to imagine
the second step to be
rate limiting as well.
However, that might not be so
common.
We will ask what's normally the
case in a reaction.
These ones where the second step
has a higher barrier are
not so common if you have an
exothermic process because
it's against the Hammond
postulate.
Not that it couldn't be, because
you have the
intermediate, and you can go
either to the product or back
to the starting material.
But if the second step is rate
limiting, it implies that you
have a higher barrier going to
the lower energy product,
which could be, but it's not so
likely.
So it's much more likely to have
these up at the top in a
reaction that's exothermic.
Of course the same reaction run
backwards would retrace
the same path, and running this
backwards would have the
second step rate limiting.
But generally we're going to
talk about cases where the
first step is rate limiting,
because we're interested in
reactions that go to give a
product, not the ones that
come back from the product and
the starting material so much.
Now if you have three different
other substituents
on the carbon that's being
attacked, other than the
leaving group that's leaving,
then you have the possibility
of chirality.
So that the first transition
state and the pentavalent
intermediate are chiral.
But the trivalent intermediate,
if it's planar,
is achiral.
And that means that there are
stereochemical implications.
Because in the first two cases
the nucleophile comes on the
opposite face from where the
leaving group is leaving.
But in the third case when you
have the trivalent
intermediate it could do that,
but it could also come in from
the other side.
So you would get two
enantiomers.
So the stereochemical
consequences, the
stereochemistry of the product,
whether it's inverted
from the starting material, or
whether it's racemic, you
attack both sides, will tell you
something about the mechanism.
I suppose if we want to be
complete in our thinking about
this, we could also imagine that
there would be a
frontside attack where the
nucleophile would come in on
the same face that the leaving
group is leaving, either in a
concerted process, or in a
process with a pentavalent
intermediate, where nucleophile
and leaving group
are on the same side.
That's a possibility, which
isn't shown here.
But whichever it is, whether
it's the same side or the
opposite side, the first two
cases are going to give a
single chirality to the product,
where the trivalent
intermediate will give both.
There are tools for testing,
that is for excluding
mechanisms. They can involve
stereochemistry, rate law,
rate constant, and structure
(X-ray work and quantum
mechanics).
In the particular book that you
might be using, the Jones
book, these are in the sections
indicated there, and
I'll indicate those as we go
along.
But these things will be covered
in all the texts, so
you'll see a good treatment
almost anywhere.
We're first going to look at
stereochemistry, what we were
just talking about.
So when you have nucleophilic
substitution, where the
nucleophile comes in place of
the leaving group, it could
either do exactly that--
it could REplace the leaving
group, so the nucleophile is
on the right in the product, the
same way that the leaving
group was on the right in the
starting material, so they
just change positions.
Or it could be a DISplacement,
where the nucleophile comes in
on the opposite side, and the
things that make
it chiral are inverted.
You could imagine either way.
If you were naive and in the
nineteenth century, which do
you think you would think more
likely?
That it would actually replace
the thing that it was
exchanging with, or that it
would come in and invert
everything?
Which do you think you would
have thought was more likely?
How many would think it more
likely if you're going to
replace something, you replace
it?
How many think it would displace
That's exactly what they thought
in the 19th century,
that it should be replacement
not displacement.
So when it was found in 1898
that there was an example,
where it inverted the
configuration, Emil Fischer,
the guy who invented the Fischer
projection after all,
who was a big expert on
stereochemistry at the turn of
the century, said this was "the
most astounding discovery in
stereochemistry since the
groundbreaking work of van 't
Hoff." which was a quarter
century earlier.
So it was really astounding to
these people that it could
invert the stereochemistry.
They thought this weird case
that showed that, was just
that-- a weird case.
But the normal case must be
replacement.
So the goal then was to find out
which one was normal.
The first really good evidence
on this, and a beautiful
experiment, was done in England
by Kenyon
and Phillips in 1923.
And it involved this alcohol,
and they resolved it, and got
a single enantiomer which
rotated light 33 degrees plus,
to the right.
Now they want to do a
substitution reaction, replace
the OH by something else, and
see whether the configuration
is the same or whether it's been
inverted.
Notice incidentally that if in
doing the process you do two
steps you'll get the same
ultimate product, whether it's
two inversions, or two
retentions of configuration.
They'll both give the same
product.
So you have to have just one
step that involves the
nucleophilic substitution
reaction.
So now in the first place, OH
minus, as we'll see later in
the lecture is a crummy leaving
group.
You can't undergo the
replacement
reaction easily with OH.
So what they did first, was to
react it with this
chlorosulfonic acid.
And this is indeed a
nucleophilic substitution,
where O attacks sulfur this
time, not carbon,
and chloride leaves.
So now you have a product where
the group attached to
the chiral carbon, is not OH but
O with sulfur on it.
Notice incidentally that nothing
happened to the chiral
carbon at this stage.
The reaction was at the oxygen.
So whatever configuration of the
carbon you had in the
starting material, you have in
the product.
This is not an interesting
reaction stereochemically.
It's just the way to get there
to be a group that'll leave.
And notice that this mechanism
is A/D. It's first
association, attack the sulfur,
and then dissociation,
lose the chloride.
And the reason you could do that
is that there's a vacant
d orbital on the sulfur.
So there's a way that you can
form a new bond without
breaking the old one.
You don't have to attack
sigma-star.
And once you have this product,
that now is a good
leaving group, because if you
break the bond between carbon
and oxygen, now the anion you
get is not OH minus, but an
anion analogous to the anion of
sulfuric acid, OSO2 Now
that has a rotation of +31
degrees, and the starting
material was +33 degrees, so
that confirms what we were
saying, that the configuration
hasn't changed
at the chiral carbon.
Am I right?
Is that a good inference?
That it's + at the product and +
at the starting material?
Does that prove that the carbon
didn't turn inside out?
How many think it proved it, or
at least supported it?
How many think it had nothing to
do with it?
Right.
Because they're different
compounds and who knows how
they're going to rotate light,
so that
doesn't prove anything.
Now we're going to do the
nucleophilic substitution
reaction where the anion is
acetate.
And it's going to attack the
carbon, and break the bond
from carbon. So the nucleophile
attacks, the
leaving group leaves.
This is the reaction we're
interested in, whether it
inverts the configuration.
And we find out that we get that
product, and that's the
nucleophilic substitution at
saturated carbon.
And the rotation of that product
is -7 degrees.
So it was an inversion right?
It shows that the carbon turned
inside out, because
it's opposite the starting
material, right?
I hear you say--
wrong!
Because it has nothing to do
with it.
Same as the first step.
So we don't really know.
That proves nothing.
The only way we're going to
prove is to get a product
that's exactly the same as the
starting material, except for
the possibility of
configuration.
Then we'll know if it's the
mirror image, but we can't use
any derivative.
So what we needed to do is
change that OCOCH3 into OH.
And you can do that.
You can bring in hydroxide,
attack the carbonyl carbon,
which generates this
intermediate, and then that
can do this reaction, breaking
the CO bond and
generate that anion.
Now there's another product, of
course.
The top right of the molecule is
this.
It's got OHCCH3, and then that
becomes a double bond.
So it's acetic acid.
Incidentally, notice this is a
substitution reaction too.
The reaction across the top was
a substitution.
The reaction coming down was a
substitution.
The reaction going at the bottom
is a substitution.
But the top was a substitution
at sulfur.
The coming down was the one
we're interested in,
substitution at a saturated
carbon.
The one going across is
substitution
at a carbonyl carbon.
That one.
So OH minus comes in, and this
anion comes off.
But again it's possible to do
that by association first, and
then dissociation, because
there's that vacant pi-star
orbital that you can go in
without
breaking anything away.
So we're not interested in the
one on the top and the one on
the bottom, we're interested in
that one that
comes down the side.
That's the reaction were
interested in.
Nucleophilic substitution at
saturated carbon.
Now notice the product.
Remember that was an acid and
this was an anion.
But of course this is a stronger
acid than hydroxide,
so the proton will be
transferred in this direction.
And now we have a product which
is the same as the
starting material, except
possibly for its
configuration.
So the question is, "Is it the
same as the starting material?"
Is the normal course of the
reaction a replacement or a
displacement?
And the rotation is -32, where
it was +33 before.
That's experimental error in the
difference.
So it's a displacement.
It inverted the configuration.
And so we know that in this kind
of reaction, backside
attack on the carbon, the kind
we anticipated, although
nobody could have thought about
it in 1923, on the basis
of a sigma-star orbital being
attacked where it's big.
So backside attack in
nucleophilic substitution at
saturated carbon.
And notice in this scheme that's
the only case where you
broke a bond to that carbon.
That's the beauty and the design
of this scheme.
Now there's another nice feature
in the
design of this scheme.
It looks a little clunky,
actually to have to do all
those things.
And you might wonder. "Why not
avoid all that stuff going
around the bottom by just doing
hydroxide attacking this
sulfonate ester?"
Because if you brought hydroxide
in there you'd get
this product, and you'd do it
without all this stuff.
But there was a reason in the
experimental
design they did that.
Because if you use hydroxide, a
much stronger base than
acetate is, then it turns out it
attacks that hydrogen, and
pulls it off, when the leaving
group leaves.
So you generate a double bond
there.
So you don't get the product.
And of course that stuff is
achiral, not
that you really care.
But you don't do the reaction if
you use hydroxide, so they
had to use acetate.
So this was a very clever
experimental design, and
proved that inversion is the
normal course, backside attack
on the carbon.
So inversion.
The trivalent intermediate could
have been attacked from
either face, and would have
given racemic product.
So we can be confident that in
this case
that's not the mechanism.
That doesn't mean there couldn't
be a case where it's
the mechanism, but it's not the
mechanism in this kind of
case, and things that are
related to it.
So stereochemistry is a good
tool, and it shows inversion.
Which means that it's not a
concerted frontside attack,
not a pentavalent intermediate
where the nucleophile came in
on the same side the leaving
group was leaving.
And it also means that you can't
have had the trivalent
intermediate.
Now let's look at the rate law,
and what it can tell us.
How the rate depends on
concentration.
So this reaction I'm showing
here is ethoxide anion attacking
ethyl bromide.
So the ethoxide replaces bromide
as the leaving group.
And we're looking at the rate of
forming the product or
losing the starting material as
a function of how much the
concentration of ethoxide is.
And we're going to fix the
concentration of ethyl bromide.
It's assumed that ethyl bromide,
which is the subject
of this whole thing, that rate's
going to be
proportional to it.
The question is, is the rate
proportional to ethoxide?
So you plot the rate as a
function of ethoxide, and you
get a line that looks like that.
So it's a second order rate law.
It's proportional to how much
ethyl bromide you have, and
it's proportional how much
ethoxide you have. So both of
those things must be in the rate
determining transition state.
Both the ethoxide and the ethyl
bromide.
Now there's something funny
about this plot.
Do you see what it is?
It's nice and linear, so it's
first order in ethoxide.
But what else?
Ayesha?
STUDENT: It doesn't start from
zero.
PROFESSOR: It doesn't start at
If you don't have any
ethoxide, you get the reaction.
How can that be?
It's because, although it's
second order--
Wait a second.
What just happened?
Did I press the wrong button?
This was just to say about the
second order.
Sorry I got out of whack here.
So the initial rate-limiting
dissociation in the
dissocation/association would
give a rate independent of
nucleophile, this one.
Because the first step doesn't
involve the nucleophile.
Only the second step.
So if the rate-limiting step
depends on nucleophile, it
can't be this mechanism.
So we could exclude it on this
basis, as well as on the
stereochemistry.
Back to this, we have the
problem that
Ayesha brought up.
How can you get the product if
there's no ethoxide?
So there must be a reaction
that's going on all the time,
whether you have ethoxide or
not.
And then another reaction that
depends on ethoxide.
What's that first reaction?
It doesn't depend on the
concentration of ethoxide, so
it seems to be a first order
process.
It's constant.
First order could be
dissociation followed by
association, so there could be
some of that
going on all the time.
And then a little bit of this
where the ethoxide attacks,
getting more and more as you
have a higher
concentration of ethoxide.
But that's not what it is.
This is done in ethanol solvent.
So the unshared pair on the
oxygen of the solvent can
attack, the same way the
unshared pair on ethoxide can.
Of course the ethoxide has a
much higher HOMO because of
its negative charge, so it will
react faster.
But there's a lot of the ethanol
there compared to how
much ethoxide, especially here
at the beginning when you
don't have any ethoxide at all.
So actually that second process
is a pseudo first
order reaction.
It depends on the concentration
of ethanol.
But ethanol solvent's
concentration is constant.
So it appears to be first order.
But it's actually a pseudo first
order process where the
first order rate constant is
k-pseudo times the
concentration of ethanol, which
is not changing.
So now we have these two
possible reactions, ethoxide
or ethanol, unshared pair,
attacking the sigma-star of
ethyl bromide.
We can tell at this point here,
when it's half and half,
half the mechanism is pseudo
first order, half the rate is
the second order.
Then we know that whatever the
difference in these rate
constants is, is made up by the
difference in
concentration, so that they have
the same rate.
That is, there's enough
ethoxide, a small amount of
ethoxide with a much higher rate
constant, so it has the
same overall rate as the pseudo
first order rate
constant does.
And from that you can figure out
that the second order rate
constant is 20,000 times faster
than
first order rate constant.
So this is 20,000 times faster
than that.
Now does that make sense to you?
Yeah, it does.
Because you'd expect the much
higher HOMO of the anion to
attack more rapidly.
How much more rapidly?
Do you have any way of measuring
how reactive these
two things should be?
These two HOMOs?
Any way of measuring how high
the relative height of those
two HOMOs, and their ability to
form a bond.
Hint it's what we talked about
in the last lecture.
Debby?
STUDENT: pKa.
PROFESSOR: pKa.
How different are they in
attacking a proton.
So, the analogy to that is
attacking protons.
And that's an equilibrium that's
easy to measure by the
way we did last time.
We find out that their pKa's
differ by 17.5 powers of ten.
Here they differ by only a
little more
than 4 powers of ten.
So you might expect it to be
even bigger, the difference.
But in fact this is measured in
equilibrium.
When you've completely formed
the bond.
Whereas in the nucleophilic
substitution, we're only at a
transition state.
We haven't completely formed the
bond.
So you don't expect it to be as
big a difference by the
Hammond postulate kind of thing.
You're only part of the way
across.
Not all the way.
So it's maybe not surprising
that seems a plausible rate
constant ratio.
So that makes sense.
So the rate law then, shows that
it can't be dissociation
first, because that wouldn't
depend on how much nucleophile
you have there.
Nor can it be frontside attack,
either concerted or
pentavalent intermediate and
then lose the leaving group.
It has to be from the backside.
Another thing you can test, is
not just how it depends on
concentration, but what the rate
constant is.
In fact we just looked in the
last slide at whether these
rate constants were plausible
for a higher
HOMO and a lower HOMO.
So the rate constant will
depend, certainly on what the
nucleophile is, ethoxide versus
ethanol.
But it will also depend on what
R is, what the leaving
group is, what the solvent is.
It also may be on the nature of
the product.
For example whether the product
is charged or not.
So all of these things will
influence the rate constant,
and we're going to look at the
whole set of them, one at a
time, and see whether these tell
us something about the
mechanism of the reaction.
First let's look at the
substrate, the R group.
Here are different R's, and the
relative rate constant for
how fast they get attacked by
iodide in acetone solvent at
room temperature, when bromide
is the leaving group.
So this is how the relative
rates as we change R. We'll
call ethyl 1.
Then, methyl is much faster.
But propyl is about the same
rate.
Isopropyl is ever so much
slower.
The isobutyl is faster again.
t-butyl is very slow.
In fact, you don't know how slow
it is.
It's got to be slower than that.
Because something else happens
other than the reaction we're
talking about.
So all you know is it can't be
any faster than that.
And neopentyl is really, really
slow.
Now, do these make sense?
Let's look at it in two ways.
First we could have substituents
on the alpha
carbon, the carbon that has the
leaving group on it.
And notice here we add one
methyl group to that carbon.
Here we've added two methyl
groups to that carbon.
Here we've added three methyl
So we can have
alpha-substitution.
But we can also have
beta-substitution.
We can add methyls to this
carbon.
Here we put one methyl on that
Here we put two methyls on that
second carbon.
Here we put three methyls on
that second carbon.
So we can try to classify it as
we put extra methyls on a
particular carbon.
So those are the
beta-substituents, for
example, one, two, or three
methyl groups on that
beta-carbon.
Now notice that as we put a
methyl group on the
alpha-carbon, the first carbon,
we add a methyl group
to it in place of hydrogen.
As we add it, it decreases the
rate by 145 times.
So there's a higher activation
energy, enough to
slow it by 145 fold.
Now let's put a second one on.
That slows it down by 128.
Another factor of 128.
About the same.
So the influence of the first
methyl group in slowing it
down is about the same as the
influence of the
second methyl group.
How about the third methyl
group?
Do you see what it does?
So that means it's raising the
activation energy by about the
same amount each time you do
that.
So you might think that the
third one would do it by that
amount, but in fact all you know
is that it's
greater than 15 times.
You can't really measure it
because
something else happens.
Now let's look at the same thing
with respect to the
beta-hydrogen.
The first one slows it down
almost not at all.
From 1 to 0.82.
Only by a factor of 1.2.
The second one slows it down by
a factor of twenty three.
But how about the third one?
Slows it by 3,000 fold!
Why does the third one make so
much difference, where the
first two don't make much
difference of adding those
methyl groups?
Well here's the case in methyl
with bromide ready to leave,
and we have to attack the
backside.
Or let us suppose we're
attacking the backside, which
seems plausible on the basis of
the stereochemistry and the
rate constant.
That means we're attacking that
LUMO.
Now let's look at that same
thing in the case of the
alpha-substitution.
There's that-- between the red
and the second blue is the
anti-bonding node that's going
to break.
Here's the surface potential.
The blue area is a good place to
put an anion,
so that makes sense.
So we have methyl, ethyl,
isopropyl, and t-butyl.
Let's look at the total electron
densities.
Notice methyl, the arrow, gets
there OK.
Ethyl gets there OK.
Although it's bumping into this
thing at the back a
little bit, but it could lean
forward just a little bit to
avoid that.
Here it's getting in trouble.
That slows it down by a factor
of 23.
Oh.
Let's see.
I've got the wrong one.
This was 100, that's another
factor of a hundred--
But this one is a much bigger
factor because you just can't
get there now when you have
three.
So the third one is what really
stops it.
And this is called steric
hindrance.
The space gets in the way.
So that's the effect of
alpha-methylation.
Let's look at the LUMO.
It looks pretty complicated.
The reason I put it up is not to
look at that, but to look
at that one orbital in the
context of the total
electronic density.
So there it is at 0.06 contour.
And now I'll put the total
electron density there, and
look through that to see how
much we can see of that LUMO
that we need to attack.
So you see, you can really see
it here.
You could see it a little bit
here, and a little bit here,
but you can't see it at all from
the backside here.
So this one is going to be shut
down.
And there's the surface
potential, and you see even
the surface potential isn't as
good here as it is in the
other ones for the anion to come
in and attack.
Now let's look at the
beta-methylation, where we
have this carbon, and we start
putting one, two or
three on that one.
And here are the rates remember.
One, 0.82, 0.036, and then
0.000012.
Why is the third one so bad?
Well you see this one can get in
there.
That one can get in there just
as well, because this methyl
group, the substituent is out of
the way.
You can put two of them out of
the way, but the third one you
can't get out of the way.
Once you have three, there's no
way to avoid it.
So that one gets slowed way
down.
No way to avoid the third
beta-methyl group.
There you can see that you can't
get any place near the
really good blue areas.
So this is consistent with the
idea that you have a
transition state that involves
backside attack.
Not the planar intermediate.
Now there's a question.
Might it be possible to have
frontside attack.
Might it be just easier to do
backside, but you could do
frontside attack if the other
one weren't faster?
How hard is it to do frontside
attack?
So is this possible?
Or is it possible to form a
cation that's not planar?
So could you have it bent, and
not planar, so that the
stereochemical consequences
would not
necessarily be inversion.
Might it be possible to have a
non-planar cation as an
intermediate?
But remember that BH3, which has
the same
electrons that CH3+ does.
Remember we talked last semester
about XH3, that when
that's a cation, or in BH3, you
expect it to be planar,
but still might not be too bad
to have bent.
This was the subject of a second
really classic
experiment in the twentieth
century.
The first one I talked about,
which I really love, is that
Kenyon and Phillips that proves
that
it must be an inversion.
But there's another one that
shows that it's not possible
to have frontside attack.
At least it's very, very hard.
And it's not possible to have a
non-planar cation.
At least it's very, very hard.
That was in this paper published
in 1939,
which if you click there you can
download a copy of the
paper, by Bartlett and Knox.
So this is your chemical
grandfather, P.D. Bartlett,
who was a young man at that
time.
He was 32-years-old, and Knox,
who was his graduate student,
who was almost the same age,
because he was an African
American, one of the first
African Americans to get a
Ph.D. in chemistry.
And if you click on that
asterisk, you can download an
account of his life, which is
fascinating.
He's the grandson of a slave,
and he has a lot of trouble.
And that's why he was old at the
time he got his Ph.D. But
you can read about it there if
you want to.
At any rate, they specifically
designed and prepared this
molecule to test the mechanistic
questions.
This is rather different than
just taking things, reacting
them, messing around, observing
what happens, and
then trying to interpret it.
They specifically designed a
molecule that would test these
questions about whether you
could have frontside attack,
whether you could have a
nonplanar cation.
And one that wouldn't be
complicated by other problems.
So they thought through very
carefully to design it.
And then Knox had to prepare it
and study it.
Now this is a comment about that
paper.
"In 1939 Bartlett and Knox
published the account of their
work on the bridge-head
chloride, apocamphyl
chloride." That's where X equals
Cl.
"I believed then, and I believe
now, that this was a
fantastically influential paper.
For thirty years afterwards, no
one really accepted any
mechanism unless it had been
tested out on
a bridgehead case.
Indeed, the Bartlett-Knox paper
shaped the interests and
viewpoint of many chemists about
the kind of physical
organic they wanted to do. "
And that's a quote from John D.
Roberts, who is an
Institute Professor at Caltech,
and one of the real
leaders of organic chemistry
through the twentieth century.
And he's still living now.
He said that in 1975.
This is the structure of that
molecule
with balls and sticks.
And it became so important, this
kind of structure, that
people who are in the field know
how to draw it quickly.
And I'll show you how to draw
it.
It has that stick structure.
And here's how you draw it.
You first form, or I do any how,
different people draw it
different ways.
But you draw this sort of a
distorted W. And then you
start at the nearest carbon, and
draw up and
down, and to the right.
And then you draw the last bond,
and you draw it last,
because it goes behind that one.
So you make it broken, so it has
a sort of a
3D aspect to it.
That's this case.
And notice what it is.
It's a boat cyclohexane.
It has a bridge across the top.
So it's a bridged compound.
And formally it's called a
bicycloheptane.
It's got seven carbons, the six
of the cyclohexane plus
the bridge.
And you give numbers in brackets
in the middle of
bicyclo to say how many carbons
there are in each bridge.
So there's a two carbon bridge,
between these two, and
a one carbon bridge.
And those two positions are
called bridgeheads.
So this is a bridgehead chloride
that we have in the
molecule of the apocamphyl
chloride that they designed
and then prepared to study.
Now here's a space filling model
of it, and there's where
you would have to attack to get
in the backside of
sigma-star.
So that's obviously out of the
question, that you
could get in there.
So the molecule was designed so
you can't do backside
displacement.
The question is if you can't do
backside, can you do
frontside displacement?
So the attack would have to be
frontside.
Now notice something else about
this structure.
That if you were to flatten that
carbon, if you were to
lose the chloride without
attacking it, and generate a
flat cation, that would require
generating really
strongly-strained angles here,
and here, and here.
And it was estimated by Bartlett
and Knox that that
would cost more than 23
kilocalories per mole.
Which 3/4 of that is 16.
So it would be 10^-16 factor in
rate.
Forget that.
So they've designed the molecule
so it can't undergo
backside displacement, and it
can't give the cation either,
lose the chloride to generate
the cation.
If you were to get a cation, it
would have to not be
planar, otherwise it would be
slowed down by 10^16 fold.
So they set up to answer those
two questions.
But there's another possible
competition.
Remember in Kenyon and Phillips,
they couldn't use
hydroxide, they had to use
acetate, because the reaction
would go otherwise if they used
the
strong base, hydroxide.
So might competition from loss
of HCl to generate a double
bond be a problem here?
Well, although there are
hydrogens on the carbon
adjacent to the carbon bearing
the chloride, there are
beta-hydrogens.
But they're not in the position
you would need in
order to get elimination.
Notice that if you had hydrogens
here, here, and
here, then you could do the
elimination.
This is anti to the leaving
group, so you to do that, and
make a double bond there.
But there are not hydrogens
here, or here, or here.
So you can't do the elimination.
Those are gauche, not anti to
the chloride
that going to be leaving.
And even if you could break off
H and Cl, this would be
the double bond you would
generate.
Now think about that double
bond.
Here's the p orbital on the
carbon that used to have the
chlorine in it.
But here's the p orbital on the
carbon that now has only
one hydrogen.
What's wrong?
They don't overlap.
There's horrid overlap.
So in fact, there's a rule
called Bredt's rule that
a carbon-carbon double bond
cannot originate from such a
bridgehead.
Incidently, I looked up Bredt's
paper yesterday, and
it's interesting that Bredt
himself calls it Bredt's rule.
Usually somebody else names it
in honor of the inventor, but
Bredt didn't wait around.
Would competition from loss of
HCl make it hard to do?
No.
So here's the beauty of the
design of this molecule.
It can't do backside
displacement.
If it forms a cation, it has to
be a non-planar cation, and
it can't do elimination, so how
reactive is it?
Well here's the part of the
paper that discusses that.
It says "all attempts to replace
the chlorine failed."
You can't do displacement on
this bridgehead chloride.
They refluxed it "for twenty-one
hours with 30%
potassium hydroxide in 80%
ethanol." And they didn't get
any reaction.
Notice they said it was a little
hard to do because
these vigorous conditions
attacked the glass, but they
didn't attack this molecule.
So that frontside attack, where
you can't come at the
backside, you have to come in
from the front, must be at
least a million times slower
than the
typical backside attacks.
So probably much, much slower
than that.
Now how about the possibility of
forming the cation.
They said they refluxed it with
silver nitrate in aqueous
ethanol solution for two days.
What's the idea of the silver?
Because silver can attack the
unshared pair on chlorine, and
form a bond, and break the bond
from the R, to leave a
cation of R. So instead of
pushing by attacking the
backside, you pull the chloride
off leaving the cation.
So that's a good way to generate
cations, except in
this case it didn't work.
There was no opalescence.
The solution remained clear.
Why opalescence?
Because if you get this
reaction, the sodium chloride,
makes a precipitate.
If you get just a little bit of
it, you can see a little
bit of cloudiness there.
But they saw none, and in fact
as you can read here, "the
reaction of silver nitrate with
1-chloroapocamphane is
least 2 x 10^-10 at about 85
degrees."
Now the reaction in this
compound, so it's carbon that
has two methyls and an ethyl on
it.
This one here is at least a
billion
times slower than that.
And when this one was measured,
it was done 60
degrees cooler, and without the
silver pulling on it.
So it's many, many, many powers
of 10 more difficult to
form this cation when it's bent.
So it's very hard to form bent
cations.
And it's very hard to do
frontside attack.
So this was a beautiful
experiment where they
specifically designed a molecule
to
answer these questions.
And it succeeded, and it became
the model for many
kinds of mechanistic studies
that were done over the next
thirty years.
Now there are also interesting
cases when the R
group is in a ring.
So here's no ring at all, just
two methyl groups, then three,
four, five, and six membered
rings.
And we're going to displace the
bromide.
Now cyclopentyl bromide is
almost exactly the same rate
as isopropyl bromide, which
we're taking to be 1 for
relative purposes.
But cyclobutyl is very much
slower, 200 times slower.
And cyclopropyl is very, very
much slower than that.
Now any ideas about why there's
no problem with
cyclopentane, but cyclobutyl and
cyclopropyl are bad.
What do you think about when you
compare those rings?
Chris?
STUDENT: Strain.
PROFESSOR: Strain.
Right, exactly.
That one has 109 degree bond
angle, and so does
cyclopentane, but the others
have very small bond angles.
Now wait a second.
This strain is in the starting
material.
If you destabilize the starting
material, you should
make a reaction faster, not
slower.
So that in itself seems to be
backwards.
What the heck is going on?
Let's think about the transition
state for the reaction.
How hard does it get from the
starting material to the
transition state?
That's what determines the rate.
So the transition state looks
like this.
And it wants-- it's sp2
hybridized to make those bonds
to the original substituents.
So it wants to have 120 degree
bond angle.
Beforehand, it wanted to have
109 degree bond angle.
Now it wants the bond angle to
be even bigger.
So if you have a 60 degree bond
angle and it wants to be
120, that's worse than having 60
when it wants to be 109.
So indeed the starting material
is strained.
But the transition state is even
more strained.
So you always have to compare
the starting material and the
transition state in a situation
like this.
So the increased strain in the
transition state is
what slows it down.
Now how about cyclohexane?
It has 109 degree bond angle
here, but it's slowed down.
It can't be this kind of thing.
It could go to 120 no problem.
No problem with making 120
degree bond angle here.
Can you see what the problem is
in the six member ring?
Why is it slower than five?
Remember the shape of the five
member ring?
It's almost flat.
A little bit puckered.
But cyclohexane is the chair,
which means that chloride is
running into these two CH2
groups right here.
In cyclopentane, those other
groups would be out
here, not up here.
And you notice that it's
strained because the line
between the leaving group and
the nucleophile is bent here.
This thing is being pushed back.
So there's a different kind of
strain in this case that slows
it down by a factor of 200,
compared to that one.
So we've seen the rate constant
dependence on R. Now
we're going to look at it just
really quickly on the
nucleophile.
So here are a bunch of
nucleophiles, and they get
faster, and faster, and faster.
Now, is it the same with the
proton?
How about the pKa's?
If we look at this, water as a
leaving group[correction; as a
nucleophile],flouride, and
hydroxide, you see that indeed,
as it gets to be a
stronger acid, it's slow.
Is that right?
A weak acid is fast. Is that
reasonable, or is that
backwards?
STUDENT: It seems like it would
be backwards.
PROFESSOR: A weak acid means it
holds
on to a proton tightly.
But it also is holding onto--
attacking a carbon well.
So that makes sense.
That makes a lot of sense.
So for first row elements, the
nucleophilicty attack on
sigma-star, parallels basicity
attack on H+.
Both require a higher HOMO,
which'll
make it more reactive.
So far, so good.
Now let's look at the halides.
Fluoride, chloride, bromide,
iodide.
Notice that as the acid get
stronger, it speeds up.
Now it's backwards.
The halides are going backwards.
The better they are at attacking
a proton, the worse
they are at attacking carbon.
That doesn't make sense.
And we see the same thing here
for oxygen and sulfur.
Sulfur is a stronger acid, but
it's better
at attacking carbon.
This seems nuts.
Now this is actually tied into
the effect of solvent.
Because if you look at the
relative rates in water for
attacking methyl iodide with
these different nucleophiles,
you see this which is
essentially what we see here.
This is 14 times faster, here's
10,000.
This is 160 times faster, here
it's 80 times faster.
These are generic numbers, and
these are specific ones for a
particular case.
But look what happens if you do
it in acetone.
It turns around.
So it's what you expect in
acetone, but it's
backwards in water.
What's special about water?
Why are things backwards in
water?
What's different about water and
acetone?
STUDENT: Water is polar.
PROFESSOR: Water forms hydrogen
bonds.
And when you form hydrogen bond
to an anion, you
deactivate it.
You have to break the hydrogen
bond in order for it to attack
something else.
So you can see that this is
sensible in acetone, but it's
backwards in water, because it's
harder to break hydrogen
bonds to the smaller ions.
So as the ions get big, like
iodide, then they're not very
much hydrogen bonded, and even
though they're not so good at
attacking protons, they're in
fact better at attacking
carbons because you don't have
to break the water away.
OK, will continue with this
stuff next time.
Thanks.